[Music]
sorry I'm late
it's fine you ready yeah
you're gonna love this
[Music]
hey jonah Jameson here spider-man a
psychopath wielding powers he has no
right to possess trying to pass himself
off as a hero well let me tell you
something kid you're no hero Mysterium
that's a hero you are a criminal a
miscreant a masked Marauder a menace
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe there you have it folks
conclusive proof that Spiderman was
responsible for the brutal murder of
Mysterio an interdimensional warrior who
gave His life to protect our planet and
who will no doubt go down in history as
the greatest superhero of all time but
that's not all folks there's the real
blockbuster brace yourselves you might
want to sit down spider-man sir whoa
straight up it's real names welcome back
everyone it's Charlie big surprise
there's a deleted spider-man far from
home post credits scene with a whole
bunch of extra J jonah Jameson footage
of him just calling spider-man out
dragging him through the press so we'll
break it down there's a bunch of Easter
eggs too because they actually launched
a legit Daily Bugle dotnet web site
where they're gonna be posting viral
teasers and Easter eggs for spider-man
stuff so we'll explain what's going on
but all those Easter eggs are there's a
new round of the giveaway for the
spider-man far from home blu-ray all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best theory about who the
villains going to be for spider-man 3 so
part of this Jay jonah Jameson clip is a
bit of a spider-man 3 teaser because the
footage he's using is of him running
across the rooftops from the end of the
movie so how did he get that footage to
put it in his video so quickly it's
probably just that this news broadcast
is meant to be from the next day because
it sounds like he has a daily web show
or a YouTube channel where he just post
these videos every single day
so he'll be dragging spider-man through
the press with these videos for the next
couple of spider-man movies remember two
more spider-man Tom Holland film
spider-man 3 spider-man 4 which might
wind up being their venom crossover
because venom to actually now looks like
it's taking place in New York City it'll
be a big question as to whether or not
they'll use this Daily Bugle net
coverage stuff in the background for
venom movies or just with the Tom
Holland Solo spider-man films I'm not
expecting him to show up everywhere all
of a sudden all over Sony's live-action
spider-man films but because spider-man
3 is taking place in New York City and
it seems like they're moving the venom
franchise towards crossover and him as a
character into the New York City area it
just makes sense that Jay jonah Jameson
would be commenting on all this in the
background
the same way he did during the
spider-man ps4 game if you haven't
played that game in a while we all kind
of assumed that when he showed up during
spider-man far from home maybe they'll
just continue to use the character this
way where you hear him just on
broadcasts in the background or people
on their phones as they're walking by on
the street listening to him bark about
spider-man and just dump all over him
while he's trying to escape whoever the
next couple of villains are going to be
right after Avengers infinity war there
was actually a funny clip that he posted
of this doing the exact same thing
before Sony ever contracted him to come
back for spider-man far from home where
it's him doing jejune of Jameson
reacting to the actual snap now keep in
mind that they won't be able to
reference the snap in spider-man 3
because of the Marvel split but it's
uncanny
how perfect it works out I'm not sure if
there are any words we can print that
will help people move on from this
unspeakable tragedy so how about we sell
some damn newspapers first headline New
York City collecting dust nobody no type
no takers okay fine let's just play the
hits somebody get Parker in here to get
some pictures of that some spider-man's
ashes headline spider-man is a dumb
idiot who's dead is out Sir Peter Parker
died in the snap died huh Parker I don't
know if you're looking down on us right
now but you're fired that's just way too
good and that was actually way before he
ever signed on to do is spider-man far
from home cameo and if you didn't notice
it - there's a daredevil easter egg in
this post credits scene - the news
broadcaster who introduces j jonah
Jameson's broadcast also showed up as a
news broadcaster during daredevil during
the Avengers Iron Man 3 defenders Doctor
Strange The Punisher and also had a
cameo in the amazing spider-man 2 with
Andrew Garfield so this is probably the
biggest point of crossover for so many
different franchises in the history of
the MCU next to someone like Nick Fury
who crosses over with everything they go
way deeper into this and the bigger
articles for the Daily Bugle dotnet
website that they created and a lot of
it's in service of the sinister six
stuff that will be coming eventually but
like I said probably only going to be a
single villain for spider-man 3 and then
they start ramping up
for bigger sinister six stuff later on
but in the same way he's going on and on
about how great Mysterio is you have to
imagine him doing the same thing about
venom when spider-man starts facing off
against venom trying to make it seem
like spider-man is the bad guy venom is
the awesome guy
we just seems like it's ripe for memes
and then all the carnage stuff is going
on too but all the reaching in the world
from him isn't gonna make carnage seem
like a nice guy in the public press the
whole point of the Jay jonah Jameson
inclusion at the end of this film / Amy
Pascal Sony and Marvel Kevin baggies
people was that they wanted to tie the
original Tobey Maguire films to the
modern films because he didn't really
see J jonah Jameson during the Amazing
Spiderman era at all they had Easter
eggs for a Daily Bugle website that they
were creating just like they did for
spider-man far from home and spider-man
3 it was gonna be an amazing spider-man
3 reveal where he shows up during that
movie but obviously they rebooted the
franchise with Tom Hollands so he never
got to see it so you look at the Daily
Bugle Ned website and some of these are
actually pretty hilarious so they have a
blip blog with a bunch of really short
posts from people talking about coming
back from the blip there's a high school
sports coach that talks about people
being blip back in the middle of a
sports game a reference to the beginning
of the film when the marching band blips
back in the middle of the game mr.
Harrington shared the story about his
wife leaving him during the blip and
using it as an excuse I found out later
that she didn't die she just left me for
someone else there's another hit piece
on the night monkey so this is him
following spider-man through the entire
events of the film so you have to
imagine that he's been blogging about
all this in the elemental stuff Mysterio
since before the movie began but there's
even an interview with Ned Leeds on this
website here so Peters probably gonna be
pretty pissed off when he finds out that
one of his best friends has been talking
to one of the people that's dragging him
in the press it just reads American high
school or nedley's is trapped in Prague
famous old town square during the
elemental attack and claims to have
witnessed the night monkeys so-called
quote-unquote heroics firsthand look the
first thing you got to know about the
night monkey is these definitely a
different superhero than spider-man he's
like some kind of European knockoff so
this is them making jokes about the
night monkey in the lines of dialogue
from the film as if he were talking to
Jay jonah jameson about it on his
website there's articles for each of the
elemental attacks with more comic book
Easter eggs so during the movie
obviously they're created by Mysterio
but they had an easy
for comic-book hydro-man when Flash
Thompson whips out his phone and is
reading about Morris bench who is
comic-book hydro-man it just reads the
elemental known as the hydro man evaded
capture by the Italian Coast Guard for
the third day in a row sparking rumors
the US government is covering up his
existence what does the Navy not want us
to know about its experimental hydro
generators why is Morris bench not
listed on any official documentation of
any kind as if he didn't even exist this
doesn't just smell fishy it smells like
a cover-up so because this is basically
what Flash Thompson was saying during
the movie you have to imagine that he
and some of the other kids are reading
this blog by Jay jonah jameson while
this is all going on there was a
question because of the Marvel Sony
split about the actors from spider-man
homecoming a spider-man far from home
coming back for remember it's just
people that originated it in Marvel
movies that they can't hundred-percent
use anybody that originated in a
spider-man movie or a Zack or spider-man
character is free to come back in
spider-man 3 so the new Flash Thompson
who's still kind of a Spider Man stand
might be going through an identity
crisis because finding out that Peter
the kid that he hates is actually the
person that he's been loving this whole
time he's inspiring he inspires me to be
a better man sup dickwad what you
drowned they might have some more fun
with him reading articles on this
website wall spider-man 3 is going on
but the bottom here this coming soon
conspiracy corner section is probably
the biggest part where they'll start
teasing spider-man 3 stuff you have to
imagine Jay jonah Jameson using this to
talk about villains in a really viral
way like there's mysterious sightings of
a person that looks like spider-man in a
black costume which winds up eventually
being the venom character so early
prediction they just wind up updating
this every once in a while periodically
over the course of them making
spider-man 3 eventually they can use
them to start teasing broader big
carnage crossover and even spider-verse
because Jay jonah Jameson understands
the concept of the multiverse and we
don't really know if he's gonna show up
during venom 2 but they're shooting
venom 2 later this year in London the
reason they're doing that is to get that
crazy-looking Gothic architecture and
make it look like really old-school New
York so that's why I say it seems like
the venom franchise is going to New York
City in venom 2 so everybody post your j
jonah Jameson theories in the comments
below how do you think that they're
going to use him during spider-man 3 and
do you
he'll show up during the venom movies in
the background - it is crazy as it
sounds while I was finishing this video
they announced that Kevin Feige is going
to make a Star Wars movie that's right
Kevin Feige is gonna have himself a star
war so that will be my next video in all
named a giveaway winner when I post that
next Marvel video while you wait for
everything click here for that Marvel
phase for an Avengers infinity saga
trailer and click here to learn all
about the Nova deleted scenes from
Avengers infinity war in Avengers end
game thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you